[Musique]
vous
après un mois passé en turquie macha et
micha posent leurs valises à l'aéroport
de tbilissi originaire de moscou ils ont
quitté la russie début mars avec leur
fils de neuf mois
la russie s'est retrouvé isolé notre
enfant n'a aucun avenir là bas il
semblerait qu'on se dirige tout droit
vers le scénario de la corée du nord ou
du retour en urss tout ça au nom d'une
idée folle d'aller libérer un peuple qui
n'a pas besoin d'être libéré de quoi que
ce soit qui est plus libre que le peuple
en russie
comme eux des dizaines de milliers de
russes ont tout abandonné pour fuir vers
la liberté
sous les cieux de géorgie
il y a des drapeaux et craignent un
partout c'est la première chose qu'on
remarque
sergei à 20 ans il est designer lui
aussi quitté moscou au tout début de la
guerre je ne pouvais pas rêver de
meilleur changement de voir tout cet
enfer de z qui t'entourent à moscou
remplacé par le drapeau ukrainien à
tbilissi
ces pesticides hors jeu
ils n'arrêtent pas de croiser des
connaissances
health émirats on devait louer un
appartement ensemble
chaque jour je rencontre des gens que
j'avais croisé en russie avant-hier j'ai
vu un gars qui m'avait vendu une
casquette à moscou
sergei est parti parce qu'à moscou déjà
il s'était engagé comme bénévole au sein
d'une ong des dalles ukraine basée à
tbilissi son activité consiste à aider
les civils d'ukrainiens à fuir les zones
que son pays bombarde
nous avons créé cette carte pour les
membres de notre équipe
elle nous permet d'élaborer les couloirs
d'évacuation pour les réfugiés
grâce à cette carte nous pouvons sauver
des gens en trouvant les trajets les
moins dangereux
parmi les fondateurs de cette ong irina
fatiha nova ex-chef du qg d'alexey
navale signé à saint pétersbourg elle a
quitté la russie en novembre dernier
auparavant toutes les structures de
l'opposant numéro un à vladimir poutine
lui-même emprisonné en russie avaient
été déclarés extrémiste par l'état russe
soudain de très nombreuses personnes se
sont rendus compte de ce vers quoi on se
dirigeait depuis longtemps déjà du point
de vue de ceux qui vivent en russie et
qui ont été confrontés à la répression
je ne crois pas que quelque chose de
nouveau est arrivé il avait préparé le
terrain en abolissant totalement la
glace nost et la possibilité pour les
gens de manifester dans la rue ils ont
détruit toutes les organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme et les
médias et je ne parle même pas de
l'empoisonnement d'alexina vague ni un
an plus tôt
mais c'est bien après l' attaque de
l'ukraine le 24 février que l'état russe
a fini d'anéantir les derniers médias
indépendants du pays
ce mardi soir si ron diet coke et
katerina coterie casey se préparent pour
leur émission hebdomadaire d'actualité
diffusée en direct sur youtube
on aurait envie d'être chez nous c'est
très dur c'est compliqué de couvrir ce
qui se passe en russie en étant à
tbilissi lui et rédacteur en chef elle
présentatrice vedette de la chaîne russe
d'opposition josh fermée depuis début
mars
en russie il ya désormais une censure de
guerre ils ont passé une nouvelle loi
selon laquelle le soin disons discrédit
des forces armées de la fédération de
russie et les prétendus fausses
informations sur leurs activités sont
punis par des peines allant jusqu'à 15
ans de prison nous avons décidé qu'en
étant libres et en sécurité en ayant la
possibilité d'informer nous serions plus
utile à nos familles et à nos auditeurs
plutôt qu'en prison
nous
voici quelques artefacts de ma vie
moscovite je les ai collé au mur
aujourd'hui il ya le billet d'avion de
mon vol de départ quelques photos de ma
mère et de ma soeur est une vieille
pellicule nous retrouvons sergei qui
partagent cet appartement de miliciens
avec trois autres jeunes russes
[Musique]
leurs discussions tournent autour des
problèmes administratifs
leur humeur aussi entre incertitudes et
espoir d'un avenir meilleur
j'ai le sentiment absolue de n'être
personne et de vivre sur un bloc de
glace en suspension au sommet d'une
montagne
de bouger
à le master
soit en france ou en angleterre
la soirée avance l'atmosphère se détend
ils ont des rêves plein la tête et le
monde leur appartient ils sont aussi
sûrs d'une chose tant que règne vladimir
poutine il n'y a pas de retour en
arrière possible pour eux